what's with the jeans can we talk about
some important issues in shortly down
yeah
number one we finally watched the season
finale of Downton yes Abbey and can I
tell you something I judge people if
they call it Downton Abbey oh my god
we're not friends
yeah I know Downton Abbey really you've
seen it and everyone's seen it written
yeah I know it's very clear what I hate
Downton there yeah yeah it's um it's
beautiful you're so good at course I
love this is when the golden retriever
the golden retrievers house is showing
you know it's such a good show no yeah I
miss it already I'm so upset that it's
over now we're late on this because we
didn't have television for the last
three weeks here I'm moved and
everything yeah I miss Downton can I
tell you what I'm really upset about
let's go through the stories yeah let's
go through it good
what's the but the guy that I don't like
what's his name
Branson no I like Branson Wade you don't
like Branson got chunkier mr. fucking
the gay dude Thomas Barrow Barrow first
of all I was up said that he didn't go
through with the suicide I really want
to mr. barrows to die that's so horrible
what what is up with you on that he was
just such a shit it's like what a short
memory be why they don't remember that
mr. barrows tried to sabotage everything
yeah and that you know I'm glad he had a
change of heart but I don't really like
him I thought it was kind of cool that
he came back and the way they tied it
together I liked it actually liked it I
liked him everybody got a nice ending
I love the Edith triumphed over Mary and
instead in terms of status yeah she
ended up with a better love match
marriage or just better marriage and
status that was cool yeah and she
actually overcame her cunt Ennis yeah
that was basically the theme of most of
that episode right was accurate cunt and
then they had Edith call her a cunt yeah
and then she saw her cunt enos and then
was like you're right I really I agree
with you I think that was really nice
and I love that final orgy scene at the
end of the episode yes so I was actually
trying to pull it up hmm yeah where
Carson finally brought out his huge hog
and Lord Grantham finally dropped to his
knees like he's wanted to for years yeah
it's great I mean and blue Carson yeah
it's because the thing is that there's
that scene where it turns out I'll just
tell you Carson has a bit of an ailment
and they're all he's kind of keeping it
hidden and then mrs. Hughes says you
have to tell everyone
so Carson in like one of the final
scenes he drops his pants and he has a
fully erect penis and he goes this is
what I've been hiding and then he he
walks over to the all the girls and he
right puts it at each of their mouths
for a moment this is the UK edition
that's right you know a lot of Americans
got to see this one we paid extra but
you get to see Carson he fucks Cora he
fucks
Lady Mary flex Edith the Dowager
Countess yeah and what I loved in the UK
Edition anyways I don't know if
Americans saw they gave they gave cousin
violet a push-up bra yes finally yes I
got to see our tits hoist it up a little
higher than
my tests usually hang solo hey Bros goes
I came back from America
push-up bra Kaza right cuz it Hogwarts
it's okay if her tits of that light
she's just teaching right but at Downton
it's not acceptable and acceptable yeah
Rose came back that little slut yep
she's got a baby now
mm-hmm and her husband's not attractive
I will say that roses will way cuter
than her husband
I agree do you think how's that going
over there
so we've filmed this in our home next
door to our child's room yeah no new
nanny
yeah who's watching our child while we
do this yep mm-hmm I was trying to find
that scene Cora Cora
fishface always with the fish that's her
face in every scene every scene and she
always goes I'm afraid not or I'm afraid
so
they're always everybody's afraid of
feelings yeah though the reason there's
never an emotional stake alone it's like
no feelings there's already come in
those bowls and then right guys always
go I should like that very much
I'm afraid that it's gonna come out of
your balls and he goes I should like
that indeed yeah I should I should like
that very much Carson I should like
cuddle me that's interesting that they
did resolve the the unanswered question
of is there any come in Carson's balls
yeah we found out yeah there's a lot of
Colin Carson's balls there's a lot yeah
there's a lot and I had her baby which
was exciting they had a boy
in fact Carson kajak you later
that's right I remember to see
this is when the servants finally come
upstairs this is Lady Mary's we've been
holding on to this for years
your lordship and Lady Shiva
everybody's happy it was a happy ending
it's not really cool the way this is a
Christmas episode yeah yeah better
you'll after I think you'll uh Carson
comes on everybody a face of life it's
really sweet ending may someone brought
the mistletoe and this is what happened
your lordship yes Carson
pretty good now I am upset because mrs.
Hughes this is happy and core I just
came yeah we heard that it's a really
beautiful show mr. barrows is even
getting in on this yeah
but in all seriousness what was Lord
Grantham's happy ending he got to see
his daughter Edith who's just his whole
adult life has just been bad luck
yeah be happy and then he saw Mary be
happy as well and Carson came on her and
that's why he saw Carson jizz all over
his daughters and then yeah yeah and
then he you know it was interesting he
was one of the people he accepted the
way that life was changing more so than
Carson those are really the
representatives of the elite of each of
upstairs and downstairs right right
Carson actually wanted to hold on to it
more so than his lordship did
interesting I'm well that's a really
good observation I mean know what I want
to know is where do they shit and they
didn't really address that he never gave
us a shitting scene in all what is it
six seasons I mean does someone have to
wipe his lordship and his ladyship her
ladyship they probably used cloth for a
while right and they're like wash wash
to his Lordships dirty I'm done wash
this oh they ring the bell and the
toilet they did it in 1850 they did they
must have had indoor plumbing at that
nice house no didn't have out houses
yeah they had they must have had some
kind of indoor well that's our really
Julian Fellowes knows the answer that
Julian does know the answer to that by
the way they would not sit with their
backs to the chairs at Downton and
there'd Wardian time your lordship you
have no more coming your balls may I
leave now go make me something nice okay
tell mrs. Patmore that make me up
something right quick is that good
that's good always wants to eat when he
comes around day all night I'll whip up
a biscuit I
always fear his lordship when he comes
it's true she does you going to wear
those tails I love that my favorite
thing ever in Downton is the time when
was it Tom came back and he didn't have
his dinner tuxedo yeah and they were
appalled that he just wore his regular
suit well it's like what type of man
that's but that's really where he goes
there like what type of fucking man what
are you doesn't travel with his you know
right his nighttime tuxedo yeah
could you imagine get I wanted it was
the kind and we found out it don't it's
all in Carson's balls series finale yeah
I loved it I just loved it where's the
kind where is the cab yep what I want to
know is who